[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt es
ist bei uns noch etwas früh am morgen
okay nicht ganz so früh aber ich bin
trotzdem mit und jedenfalls habe ich mir
trotzdem überlegt heute einen muss
kuchen zu backen und zwar wird es ein
saftiger schokoladenmousse kuchen hoffe
ich zumindest das rezept probieren wir
jetzt nämlich einfach zusammen direkt
aus und ich denke gerade so im herbst
ist das kochen schon lecker also ich bin
der totale für ein bonus kuchen
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht deswegen
dachte ich werde das jetzt mal ein
schöner kuchen den ihr auch sonntags
genera zu bereiten können für alle mal
wieder ein bisschen was einfacheres denn
ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen also
torte mache ich schon ganz gerne aber
ich esse wenn ich kuchen oder torte als
wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste würde
ich mich schon eher für den kuchen
entscheiden so linzertorte loskugeln
schokokuchen aber tut es auch lecker
aber heute gibt es okay
dafür nehme ich 200 g weiche butter 200
gramm zucker eine prise salz und etwas
vanille extract 6
die sind bereits zimmer war 250 gramm
haselnüsse 200 gramm schokolade streusel
125 gramm mehl einen teelöffel zimt ein
päckchen backpulver ist in drei
teelöffel und etwas milch statt milch
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch in gläschen
rum nehmen für das aroma warum trägt
auch dazu bei dass der kuchen ein
bisschen schöner aufgeht was ich jetzt
zuerst mache ich nehme hier die
haselnüsse die sind im ganzen und die
werde ich jetzt schön auf einmal oder so
ein bisschen grob mal dadurch also wenn
ihr ganz übernimmt ist halt dass der
vorteil dass er wirklich noch das volle
aroma in nüssen habt und dann werden sie
noch an gerüstet und dann entfalten sie
ihr komplettes album also habt ihr
wirklich sinnvolles geschmack
die nüsse jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
rösten ohne fett bis der lecker durften
immer mal wieder umrühren
das könnte auch im backofen machen aber
ich finde den opfern da geht es auch
wirklich super einfach und ich kann in
der zwischenzeit schon mal hier die
weiche butter mit dem zucker verrühren
und da ist wirklich bei dem rührkuchen
einfach nur wichtig alle zutaten zimmer
warm zu haben
damit eben nichts gewinnt und lockt
zucker und salz dazu natürlich bisschen
vanille extrakt dazu und dann hilfe etwa
vier bis fünf minuten cremig verrühren
so soll sich die masse dann aussehen
also der zucker lässt sich wunderbar auf
und es ist einfach nur schöne luftige
masse jetzt gibt hier die eier einzeln
dazu lasse jedes ei ungefähr eine halbe
minute einrühren und in der zwischenzeit
sollten auch die haselnüsse schon schön
abkühlen und ich geb dir ganz gerne
immer auf so ein ermittler
denn er hat den vorteil dass ist die
temperatur einfach raus zieht aus den
lebensmitteln das heißt ihr könnt dinge
schnell kalt bekommen ihr können sie
schnell warm bekommen also je nachdem
wie es eben braucht und so kühlen die
haselnüsse eben richtig gut und schnell
ab denn wenn die hasen minister jetzt zu
warm sind und ihr sie gleich dazu gibt
schmilzt die butter und dann ist die
ganze luft die ihr 1 geschlagen habt
einfach wieder weg und das wäre ziemlich
schade
[Musik]
na toll jetzt sieht mein tag auch
gesellig aus aber den hätte ich jetzt
und zwar mit etwas ich habe hier auch
schon mal die trockenen zutaten
vermischt
die kann ich jetzt so ein bisschen gebe
ich jetzt was rein damit die masse
wiederfindet jetzt wo mein gott oh mein
gott was mach ich heute
ich sagte ich kinder so müde okay wir
brauchen keine 250 können wir nehmen nur
230 mit äpfeln und zimt das so geben
auch jetzt gebe ich auch noch die
streusel rhein ist auch die theke die
milch noch dazu
lieber mit spritzschutz heute arbeiten
ist sicherer und ganz kurz verrühren
also jetzt wirklich nur noch kurz nicht
lange bis sich alles verbunden hat
perfekt ich finde der teig sieht optimal
ausrichten und hat eine tolle konsistenz
den ofen habe ich bereits vorgeheizt auf
170 grad ober unterhitze ich pack das
ganze jetzt immer guglhupf ihr könnt ihn
auch in den backen backen falls ihr
keine good luck vom habt oder in der
kasten kuchenform das geht auch ich fand
die ziehung der guglhupf form richtig
richtig schön
und dann hätte ich jetzt die form mit
max renz bay
so kommt man ganz einfach überall dran
ich sag's dir heute und dann ist die
frau schnell gerettet und in dem wollt
könnt ihr noch brotkrümel nehmen also
semmelbrösel so zum ausstreuen reform
muss nicht sein aber könnt ihr machen
ich finde dadurch hat es auch eine tolle
konsistenz so am rand von ein bisschen
knusprig
und dann den teig hineinfühlen
[Musik]
vielleicht noch zur info das waren jetzt
keine back festen schoko drops sondern
einfach nur schokoladen streusel da gibt
es auch so ein kuchen der heißt aber
weisen kuchen das handy auch mit drin
weil es eben irgendwie außer dieser
kleine arbeiten kochen kann ich auch
gerne mal machen wenn ihr den sehen
wollt und die finde ich immer mega
leckerem kuchen weil die einfach auch so
schön weich dann sind und sich mega gut
verteilen also da muss ich sagen bin ich
voll erkennt von streuselkuchen okay
und jetzt wird er schon gebacken ich
packe ihn jetzt wie gesagt hier im
vorgeheizten backofen was wir auch
machen könnt falls ihr die bosch serie 8
habt da gibt's nämlich den bug sensor
den zeige ich euch gleich mal da können
sie einfach den kuchen in kalten ofen
schieben den bug sensor einschalten und
müsst dann nicht mehr darauf achten wann
auch fertig ist ich mache es ist
natürlich so ganz traditionell dass ich
für euch die richtige backzeit habe aber
wenn ihr den bug sensor schaltet sich
der backofen ganz automatisch von
alleine ab wenn der kuchen perfekt gar
ist also ihr braucht man keine
schnäppchen probe mehr mist keine zeit
mehr nachstellen und habt einfach immer
die perfekte gleiche konsistenz
den bug sensor findet ihr hier
untermenü es sitzt dann geht er auf
kuchen brot und pizza gibt dann auf
kuchen und es ist ein kuchen in der form
also hier
und dann steht hier direktbank senser
automatik tipp form auf brusthöhe 2 und
fertig der koran ist abgekühlt den kann
ich hier schon mal raus lösen
[Musik]
als ich habe ihn echt komplett in der
form abkühlen lassen
so ist jetzt perfekt und ihr könnt ihr
entweder so lassen oder noch eine
klausur draufmachen ich mach jetzt eine
art retter schokoladenglasur drauf hab
jetzt auch schon 200 gramm
bitterschokolade fein gerieben und jetzt
müsst ihr die schokolade gut
temperierten damit sie später schön
glänzt und keinen grauen schleier ist
sich kein grauer schleier bildet
deswegen hier zwei drittel abmessen und
ein drittel
die zwei drittel kommen hier direkt in
eine schmelz schale und dann direkt hier
erwärmen und ich habe ich das war's auch
schon kochen essen habe den herd wieder
ausgestellt so verhindert er auch ein
überhitzen
und wenn die schokolade geschmolzen ist
neben dem herd herunter also jetzt hat
sie so ungefähr um die 50 grad und damit
sie jetzt wieder herunterkühlt auf circa
30 grad gibt man jetzt eben das
restliche drittel dazu gerne auch schon
mal das kokosöl kokosöl dienst jetzt
hier dazu dass die schokolade nicht mehr
zu festwirt und beim anschnitt die
schokolade eben nicht so bricht so habt
ihr gleich die perfekte weitere
verarbeitung des temperatur
[Musik]
doch ein bisschen geduld ein paar
stückchen sind noch drin aber dann
setzte auch perfekt jetzt ist die
kuvertüre perfekt und ich lasse jetzt
hier direkt über den kuchen fließen
jetzt ist die kuvertüre perfekt und ich
lasse jetzt direkt über den kuchen
fließen
am besten setze den wirklich auf und
abkühlt darunter natürlich ein blech zum
auffangen der kuvertüre dann einmal hier
über den rand
[Musik]
ich überlege was ich schöner findet wenn
der kuchen noch durch guckt oder wenn es
komplett gestrichen ist wofür seid ihr
jan ist schon schön aus so dass sturm
sich dort gut auskennen ach ich was denn
jetzt
ich wollte ihn eigentlich echte komplett
ein streit habe sieht gut aus
einigen wird ihm jetzt ganz bestreitet
roger sarah sein hartes futter auge
sarah ok sarahs stimme
ok foto auge
ich wollte ich brauch nur kurz deine
foto auge was sagt dein foto auge den
kuchen komplette streichen oder runter
laufen lassen allerdings kein foto audi
geht nachgeschmack weil sie will hat am
rand komplett über alcoa tiere so den
knapp der kritik
das ist schon das war auch gut so ein
gedanke aber ich lasse es jetzt so ja
alle einverstanden
und jetzt stehe ich hier einfach noch
krokant auf die torte haselnuss krokant
mainz perfekt passt du machst sara kurz
bilder der jungs macht auch schöne
bilder und dann froh wären wir den
kuchen und bei dem kuchen ist es
wirklich so der wird von tag zu tag
saftiger und besser je mehr durchzieht
der gucken und dann okay afrika aus
kurzen schnitt
[Musik]
und die schokolade da unten bitte nicht
wegschmeißen sondern da gibt es auf
meiner seite ganz viele resteverwertung
ideen wie zum beispiel rockets genau
salzbrezeln rein und marshmallows und
gefriergetrockneten werden und dann
könnte die quartiere einfach weiter
benutzen
also die sarah hat jetzt wunderschöne
bilder gemacht wie man hilft bei den
bildern
ich hab mir den bilder schon dachte er
sich so saftiger für mich auch kein
trick steige ich mal ein hemd ist das
ein fetisch weil mein rohstoff video
konform ist ja ok ja komm wir probieren
manchmal ziehe ich einfach meine sache
gut zu wissen
ich liebe immer den blues unseren kummer
aus ist ein bisschen so dass das hatte
dann am rand ist mit schokolade zu
springen doch ist schon gut ich will
kurz sagen das ist mittlere
schokostreusel sind innen drin herschel
streife ja zu einer tram mehr
schokostreusel als mail du hast schwarze
da das in die schokolade kauf also von
daher also wenn man es gut gern schon
genau perfekt und ich würde auch kurze
ist perfekt also probiert den kuchen
gerne mal aus und er bleibt um wirklich
mehrere tage saftig und wenn ihr was
übrig habt natürlich bleibt
wahrscheinlich nichts irgendwelche mal
da ist sofort aufgegessen und dann
probiert ihn einfach aus und ladet fotos
davon und lag mit uns ein uns lauter
bunter ich schreib daraus kontaktdaten
direktionen rein
ich weiß ich weiß was für die nachricht
dann auch klopp
ok also viel spaß und nachmachen bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]